من هنا بدات العمليه ما يزيد عن 50 اليه
عسكريه اقتحمت مخيم نور شمس في عمليه هي
الاضخم في تاريخ المخيم نفذ الاحتلال
خلالها حمله اعتقالات ومداهمات طالت ما
يزيد عن 100 منزل تم خلالها اعتقال ما
يزيد عن 300 فلسطيني فيما افرج الاحتلال
عن ما يزيد عن 200
وبقي قرابه ال تم نقلهم الى مراكز التحقيق
قوات الاحتلال باعداد كبيره خرجت من
المنطقه من بوابه 104 وصولا الى حجز الى
حاجز السكه ومن ثم الى مخيم نور شمس هنا
بدات الاليات العسكريه فعلا
بالخروج من مخيم نور شمس مخلفه دمارا
واسعا في البنى
التحتيه اعتقالات وملاحقات وتدمير في داخل
المخيم بدات بالفعل هذه العمليه العسكريه
وشارفت على الانتهاء بانسحاب عدد كبير من
الاليات العسكريه برفقه الجرافات فيما
تعمل بعض الاليات على تامين خط انسحابهم
نحو بوابه 104 الى الغرب من مدينه طول كرم
اذا تواصلت هذهه العمليات العسكريه
وانسحبت او بدا الانسحاب بالفعل من داخل
هذا المخيم هذه الاليات العسكريه اقتحمت
المخيم برفقه جرافات وقامت بتدمير البنى
التحتيه داخل المخيم من مدينه طول كرم ليث
جعار الجزيره